So by the year 2050,
there are going to be
more than two billion people
who are older than 60 years old,
and it has been estimated
that around 80 percent
of these two billion people
will live in low-
and middle-income countries,
which is roughly the developing countries.
It is currently a common belief, globally,
that senior citizens should not work,
do not need to work,
and therefore, there is no reason
for companies to create jobs for them.
I think this kind of thinking,
the thinking that senior
employment is inessential,
is actually the seed of a major problem
that could impact a lot of lives,
especially the lives of people
in developing countries.
To explain to you why,
let me show you a diagram,
and let me call this diagram
a negative aging spiral.
Imagine a 50-year-old
living in a developing country.
The chance that this person
will work later on will be slim,
so this person is not going
to invest in their skill,
might not even invest in their health,
because there's no return
from this investment.
Then, at the age of 60,
this person is going to stop working,
because it's a common thing to do
in these countries.
And then after that,
many bad things could happen.
For example, this person might not
have enough savings,
or maybe no savings at all,
and now there’s no more
employment opportunity.
This person might feel lost,
feel hopeless, feel lonely.
This person might even feel
like there's no purpose
to continue living.
So it seems like, for many people
in developing countries,
there's going to be suffering
through the process of population aging.
Is there anything we can do differently?
For me, as an economist
who has been working on this topic
of population aging,
especially in the context
of developing countries,
for many years,
I have been puzzled by these questions,
but I think I've got an answer.
I think the best catalyst that we can use
to break the negative aging spiral
and unlock the power of population aging
is to create something called
senior employment technologies
and use it to democratize
senior employment.
What is senior employment technology?
It is a technology that can be used
to reduce or remove
physical and cognitive barriers
for work for senior citizens.
Like people wearing glasses today,
which we use to erase or remove
our vision problem,
senior employment technology
is something that we can use
to transform senior employment
from scarcity to abundance.
But unfortunately,
this aspect of technology
has been overlooked
by a lot of people.
When we actually think about it,
senior living assistive technologies
are quite common,
but not so much in terms
of senior employment technologies.
And in the context of,
for example, developed countries,
these technologies
do exist to some extent,
but in the context
of developing countries,
these technologies
are largely nonexistent.
So if we could create
senior employment technologies
and use our imagination
to think about what it could be,
what would it look like?
Let me give you guys a couple of examples.
The first group of senior
employment technologies
is something that can be called
physical augmentation technologies.
There are two types
of physical barriers to work.
The first one
is physical barriers at work.
So as we age, we tend to lose
some of our physical abilities.
For example, we lose our muscle strength,
we might lose
our hand and finger dexterity.
Now, let's imagine the possibility
we could create cheap and accessible
exoskeleton technologies,
which is a suit that a senior
citizen could wear,
and this suit can be used to augment,
for example, trunk muscles,
and the senior citizen can actually
use it to lift something heavy,
but it doesn't feel that heavy.
Now, if we actually think about it,
this aspect of technologies
could be pretty important
in the context of developing countries,
because a lot of people
in developing countries
actually use their body
or their labor, a lot, for work.
Next, let’s imagine
the possibility we could create
cheap and accessible collaborative robots,
or "cobots" in short,
which is often in the form of robot arms,
and these robot arms can be used
as an extra steady hand
that a senior citizen could use to recover
their hand and finger dexterity,
especially for work
that requires precision.
One interesting use case for this
could be ... senior surgeons
in developing countries.
We can all agree that we wouldn't want
a surgeon with a shaky hand
to do anything near our body.
But these technologies
can help senior surgeons
with amazing skill, amazing knowledge,
to still make a significant contribution.
And we know, in the period
of population aging,
surgeons, doctors
will be in great shortage.
The next physical barrier to work
is the physical barrier
in getting to work itself.
So as we age, things
like getting stuck in traffic
or being in congested
public transportation for so long
only to take a long walking distance
could be a major barrier to work
for many senior citizens.
Now, if a job does not require
a physical presence,
let’s imagine the possibility that remote
working technology such as Zoom
or maybe, in the future, the metaverse,
can be used to completely remove
the journey to work itself,
and allow senior citizens
to work from anywhere,
any time, or maybe any country.
If a job does really require
a physical presence,
let’s imagine the possibility
of smart city technologies.
One aspect of smart city technology
is focused on optimizing
city transportation resources
by collecting data, information,
from sensors or cameras,
and using it to improve the journey
to work for senior citizens
so that their journey to work
can be better and safer.
The second group of senior
employment technologies
is something that can be called
cognitive augmentation technologies.
So as we age, we also tend to lose
some of our cognitive abilities.
For example, we tend to lose
our ability to memorize things
or our abilities to compare
pictures, objects,
which is called perceptual speeds.
Let’s imagine the possibility that maybe
our cell phone, our laptop
or maybe virtual reality glasses
can be equipped with cognitive
augmentation software
powered by artificial intelligence,
which can be used as a companion brain.
So in the future, this device
can be used to help senior citizens,
senior workers,
to show them work-related
information as needed,
so they don't need
to memorize everything --
which would be great
for me right now, too --
(Laughter)
help enhance, for example,
perceptual speeds
when senior workers, senior citizens
need to identify objects or find defects,
and they can actually make
the final decision better and faster.
Of course, beyond the physical
and cognitive barriers
that I have mentioned,
we still need to find a way
to remove social barriers to work,
which is called ageist beliefs.
It's the belief that senior citizens
are always less productive
than younger workers
for any kind of occupation.
I think senior employment technologies
can take us one step closer
to removing, or maybe
significantly reducing ageist beliefs.
I think if we can do this thing,
we can break the negative aging spiral
and create something that can be called
a positive aging spiral.
Imagine a 50-year-old
living in a developing country,
but in this case, this person
actually invests in their skill,
this person actually invests
in their health,
because they know
this investment will be valued.
And not only that,
this person actually looks forward
to the next journey in their lives.
Then at the age of 60,
senior citizens who are qualified to work,
or could become qualified to work,
because of senior employment technologies,
and need or want to work,
should be able to work.
If we can do this,
I think we can achieve and become
a wealthy and healthy aging society.
So by using these senior
employment technologies ...
When we think about technologies ...
some technologies might seem scary,
some might seem concerning.
But I think senior employment technologies
is the right kind of technology
that our world, our society
needs more right now.
And we can use
senior employment technologies
to transform and democratize
senior employment,
from scarcity to abundance.
And I think we can use it to transform
the lives of many people
from suffering through the process
of population aging
to flourishing in the process
of population aging.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)